so i want to start off this video by
just saying thank you and especially
thank you for following me on twitch i
recently hit 200 000 followers which was
a huge milestone and to celebrate i ran
a viewer tournament a few days ago it
was kind of spur of the moment i created
the tournament while streaming and had
some really fun exciting games which
you'll see in this video now as usual
every game is time stamped as a chapter
in the video description so feel free to
hop around or just watch the whole thing
and i do hope you enjoy the video now
before we get to the chests i do want to
thank the sponsor of today's video which
is skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes ranging from business design
photography video production
pretty much any type of software you can
imagine there's a class for it on
skillshare and it's a great platform to
explore new interests or improve on
existing ones now one class i've been
taking recently that i've really been
enjoying is how to edit with final cut
pro by youtuber ali abdal
this class does a great job breaking
down the basics of final cut pro
and tips and tricks for improving your
overall workflow and general best
practices from a leading expert in the
field so if you want this class or
thousands of others on the skillshare
platform i do have a special offer for
my viewers the first 1000 people to
click the link in the video description
we'll get a one month free trial to
skillshare so you can start learning and
exploring everything the platform has to
offer
and with that let's get back to the
chess
okay good luck
i'm playing oh i'm playing the 2600
i might not be hard to win as quickly as
possible
opponents from india
uh let's
play probably now the budapest okay
definitely not the budapest
i'll play my main thing
yeah london i'll play as aggressively as
possible here
knight d2 i'm going to take and play
bishop by 5.
solid but still dynamic
approach
there's a line queen b3 bishop d6
bishop e2 bishop d6
and the plan is to eventually go for the
minority attack
like a6b5
um probably queen c7
we have a reverse queen's gamut exchange
variation
which uh
i think is comfortable for both of us
playrook c8
yeah this is not the type of position i
was kind of expecting but
it's kind of what i have to do against
the london
394
knight g3 bishop g6
e3
okay so a5
trying to clamp down
[Music]
go play this move
this might turn into a waiting game
actually
a lot of players already won their first
game that's crazy
like queen c7 and tickling the pawn
and some idea bishop h5
um
i'm just trying to apply pressure
had the thought of taking and then
moving the knight in
i don't think that accomplished as much
though
another idea is to
bring the queen in
what to do maybe this move
okay third idea is to play this and this
this f4 square looks really nice for
knight
okay vision d1
doesn't really scare me
g4 might scare me
g4 traps my bishop
but it would have been kind of risky for
white
okay we have a nice
cube of knights
um
[Music]
what's going on here have to trade
bishops i guess
oh there's a tactic almost i think it
works
in 92 and knight d4
using the fork and the pin
okay there's a pin on the c file
now i can take here
and whatever it takes whatever i have
knight b3 okay this knight has to be
taken
and knight b3 is coming
as a safe pre-move too
okay that's a free pawn
i didn't realize the pawn was hanging
until
right before i took it
okay that was a nice game
relatively quick win
right behind lost king
only player to win two games
yeah that game i had to be like patient
and solid in the opening and
gradually improve my pieces
um
yeah sometimes if the opponent plays
solidly it requires
more patience than normal
okay playing alireza gm
1020
oh from a neighboring country
uh
play
play some grand prix how about
f4
so there's a line to play
d4 but i think i can just play this
immediately
this knight is already
questioning its purpose in life
and now
oh the f pawn's attack though
maybe g3
i wasn't actually sure if taking like
benefits me or benefits black
okay
well complete development the long term
plan is to attack on the king side
i took away from the center to open the
d-file also
accelerate development of the bishop
okay i'll take queen e2
i do bishop e3
quick question are people hearing the
move noises
because it doesn't show in the audio
oh there's no chest sound why is that
because chrome is
i have no idea why that is
i might have to update my audio
interface
sorry about that
i could also maybe do this
oh
okay wait
to focus on the game first
um if i take on c6 and play queen h5 i
think this is absolutely crushing
it feels weird to give away my bishop
it might be a little bit risky too
the black is suffering with these pawns
yeah oh no my sound
i just realized too i don't know what's
going on
properties
i could restart the application
how about now okay i think i fixed it
there's a b7
yeah i should have been calculating
there good black's running mate
good morning
i'm thinking takes in rook f3
it feels weird but
you gotta do what i gotta do
this can be pre-moved
good morning to andros
zero
appreciate the bits
okay now let me know if the move noises
are too loud or too quiet or just right
okay here i can take the pawn
also move back but
i'll take the pawn
threatening the bishop also threatening
this probably
though maybe not
the knight is tied down to the rook
sound is just right okay that's what i
like to hear
queen h3 is a move
it's a tricky position
you h3 h6
man i really want to do crazy things
i'm going to do crazy things
i mean f6 and rook t6
i don't think it works though
it looks fun
oh queen c7 in that line
good luck to everyone participating in
rose and let's go let's go okay
i'm really unsure here
queen
[Music]
d6
okay i'm gonna play this because i
really wasn't sure
maybe rook here
such a sad move though do this move
allowing queen h1
because now the queen defends g2
um
so if queen h1 i have king f2
and the idea is just to bring my knight
back
yeah that's a scary move though
rook here i guess
it looks a little bit shaky
it's probably
i don't know if it was a mistake but it
maybe wasn't the best practical decision
to give up my electorate bishop
maybe there were better things i could
have done
at least here i'm surviving
i think my king wants to be here
okay now i don't have to worry about the
queen
invasion
i'm ready to move the knight back
and maybe even reroute to
h4 and g6
from each word still defend the g2
but would allow queen h1
also lying the rook on e8
which could be relevant in some lines
oh what to do
i think this is okay
i'm gonna have to take with bishop
or knight
rook e2 wow
it should still be okay
it looks like black should have some
tactic here but uh
i don't think there's any tactic
black wants to take here
but after rook takes we train on f3 the
bishop is hanging in the end
so that's a move
um
[Music]
yeah this is actually a terrifying
position
king of one
to hold on for dear life
holding on by a thread
there's no g6
trade rooks i'll be okay
oh c4 is hanging
or c2 is hanging if you can just say
i have this move maybe
mcqueen covers c5
ideal knight g6
or maybe even queen e2
opponent's played a good game so far
hey g6
i'll play this
i just realized i'm still up a pawn
okay let's trade and play an end game
i'll play this move
time to start pre-moving
hey thanks for subbing my friend
44 welcome back
good to see you too
just in time for the the time scramble
okay sorry to my opponents the final
position was a draw
and that wasn't necessarily winning as
quickly as possible
but i got the job done
35 minutes left played two games so far
osama style wow winning so many games
okay catching up to do
can we have a ponziani
if i'm white i'll play e4 and i would be
more than willing to go into ponziani
okay playing
rasmus plays chess
staff for gamba time
staff for gamma time
i'm scared my opponent might know what
they're doing
but we'll see
i want to play g4
go eric
this is uh
the dubious way of meeting h3 but the
most fun way
is there's some
yeah tricks and drops to this
thank you golem
i think white's still objectively better
here
despite the fact i
unleashed some type of tactical sequence
i'll put my queen on e5
um white can't castle
but there's rig f1
so i guess i'll play king e7
there weren't too many other ways to
defend there
the position actually looks a little bit
shaky
but it's kind of shaky for both of us
like both kings are stuck in the center
if i get the chance i probably want to
play this move
and again for those just joining uh this
is a viewer tournament
people are more than welcome to use a
join command
that was a
really good move actually
kind of play this move
yeah i might be getting badly punished
here
or not
okay at least we treat queens
and now
i have f2 i don't think i can take the
pawn i have this move too
try and get my knight to e5
yeah white have a lot of ways to really
punish me there
there was some d4 opportunity earlier
there was also bishop c5 which i think
was working
[Music]
it's still very risky
i'm just trying to stay alive
uh maybe h6
if i played this too soon there's rook
f6
okay hitting the g pawn i bumped into
two chess masters in the lobby of a
hotel bragging about how good they are
oh chestnut and chestnuts boasting in an
open foyer
yeah wait foyer
foyer or foyer
i've always pronounced it foyer
but now i'm
doubting myself
okay i'm about to win king of the hill
let's go controlling the center
oh no my queenslight pawns
the nice thing is if rook c7 i have rook
a f8
and then
white's king could be in the pickle
so i'm down the pawn here
i feel like there's compensation my
king's very active
idea to play b4 soon either win this or
this
or both
and the knight's a bit misplaced
threatening rook d2
king e3 is a good move
go play this move then rook g3
[Music]
time to
calculate okay i'll play b4 schedule is
weird 2 am and 6 am streams
it's actually very normal
my sleep schedule is the most normal
it's been like the whole last month
or out of the whole last month it's the
most normal it's been out of the last
like two years
because i'm on dubai time
yeah i should have figured this out
earlier because the way to fix my
sporadic sleep schedule is to
just travel across the world where
my sleep aligns with uh
the day and night
and bishop
wait a minute their tactics rookie one
wait this is a free night
i was thinking removal of the guard
rather than taking the free piece
okay
i was calculating rookie one king d2
it was the simplest tattoo in chess
okay time to focus
e4
that game was really uh risky we'll play
a different opening this time
play smith mora
and i'll insist on playing the smith
aura
even though black's probably not going
to take here
stick with bishop
this is already new for me
maybe take with queen
now this could be a threat
should have 7 knight g5
if it was my move i think i would take
on f7
so i'm in fifth place
man osama style is uh
it's crushing it right now
without even berserking
yeah that's a very respectable move
um
bishop g5
i have to defend the pawn
in this move
because there's a line like knight c6 we
trade you see it should all be okay
if we trade queens it's gonna be hard to
get any sort of attack
and this might turn into a more
positional game
yeah now if i if i take on f7 and the
king could take it then run away
whoa it's toggy what's up hello hello
hello yo hello chat hello time long time
long time no see what's up tagi
good to see you you're just in time for
the last 27 minutes of the the viewer
tournament
if you want to join
everyone's encouraged to use their
talking emotes
yeah it's been a while for both of us
i hope life is good in iceland
opponent
wants to win my pawn
um
yeah there's a really risky line bishop
a6 knight a5
living on the edge
i just want to take here in the event of
trading
all fork stuff in the end
and if like if black defends and i
defend
yeah what time is it in iceland
four hour difference
what's what like late morning
sometime in 2022 i will be
venturing to iceland
maybe for reykjavik open if they hold it
okay delayed london
it's going to be hard to castle given my
king has no legal moves
all these squares are controlled around
my king
black had a funny idea to play rook d1
knight f2
probably wouldn't have been good though
uh that's a good move
h3
h3 probably doesn't work
oh there's a funny line to play b4
not sure if it works so
i might try it
you trade everything
wait i'm up a pawn here i don't have to
defend
i just have to consolidate
when do i win a pawn
oh wait no
until they win the pawn
[Music]
oh opponent played d5
it kind of escaped my mind that i won a
pawn
okay so now material is equal that's
good to know
so i don't have to go like super crazy
i can just try and trade
and then try and outplay my opponent
with my knights
okay
yeah i might be slightly worse here
though
oh there's a funny line okay i'm gonna
play this move
and then king d1
it looks like i'm completely passive
inviting this move
but there's a sneaky trap
i think
maybe not
it's complicated
i'm looking at rook e2 knight c5
hitting the bishop
the black's a little bit unstable
because of this or this
i have this or this
the problem is rookie 2 or rook b2 after
knight c5 and if i take the bishop
there's rook b1
uh i'm stationary right now
at least in my chair
but i'll be traveling
yeah i'm i'm still in dubai
i'll be traveling home at some point in
the future
but i still don't know when
[Music]
also thanks for subbing tagi for 32
months
and thanks again for the bits
i don't think knight c5 works
because of rook b2
so this is a backup plan is
oh no all of my pawns
but then at least i'll win a few pawns
and
maybe make things spicy
up on time here
i have the knight too knights can be
tricky in
these low time situations
yeah rook a2 and then for k7 there's
bishop
e2 that's a move
i think i can take
i don't mind the trade on b3
because now black can't win any of these
pawns
and surprisingly i have a more active
king
and a more active rook
tides are turning
yeah there's a strategy in rook endings
to put the pawns like this so it becomes
more difficult for the rook to later
take the pawns
my king is in range of attacking but
also in range of defending
so now i'm up a clean pawn
i'll keep my rook on that floor the
whole king side is defended
and try and make progress on the queen
side
maybe some c4 idea
or some rook check
throw in some spike checks
that's kind of annoying though
i've f3
let's move back
this might objectively be a draw but
okay let's start pushing
put the rook on f no let's not put the
rook on f3
walk the king up first
i want to put the rook on e3
soon there we go and then f4
now the pawns are happy
okay
so the whole strategy of trying to win
games as quickly as possible
it's not fully working whoa it's gary
gary's also streaming this tournament
and lichas isn't even detecting my
stream
[Music]
oh that's so funny gary's maybe winning
this tournament too
[Music]
i see the comment
good you're not up a dirty pawn
okay uh
let's play this move
i forgot to mention leeches.org
okay let's play
uh let's play aggressively
i'm gonna play this e5 line
it's my new weapon against kyrokhan
okay
h4 coming soon
just trying to change the stream title
the chess
okay so i played this yesterday's stream
it's a gambit line because i'm going to
play e6 next move assuming bishop h7
so i sag my e pawn
and i play d4
and the point is to
uh to make it difficult for black to
develop the king side
play bishop d3
because once we trade lights for bishops
and light squares will be
a lot weaker on the king side
idea queen d3 next
now it's going to be hard to stop queen
g6
the taking away lacks casting rights
would really love to play bishop f4
but this position might call for a
little bit of patience
oh there's an idea rook h4 and then just
about four
not the most normal move to consider
okay e5
probably need to react to this i have
knight f5
queen e6
oh life is confusing right now bishop e3
maybe
idea to after take take back i blocked
the discover check
i have initiative on the queen
i i would hate to trade queens here
so
let's lose more pawns
i'm completely okay with losing pawns
if queen g2 i'll castle queenside
okay i'm looking at this move
knight takes c6
uh yolo
so if pawn takes i win the knight
if king takes
i'll try and figure things out
the plan was probably queen b5 there
so now black could
gonna say could fork me
that's a solid looking move
well i can't legally castle queenside
maybe 94
i'm again living on the edge
so gary with 20 tournament points
uh let's try to check in knight c5
not sure this leads to much
wow i suck the night
it's really risky
i'm gonna do it though because
i'm trying to win quickly
ideas of pawn digs i play f3 i lose this
pawn then like queen's like [ __ ]
oh no i missed queen after queen
queen g3 chuck
okay now i'm just in big trouble
yeah queen f2
ah there's almost a funny line
if i play
i have to play king c1 i guess
to run away from danger
queen c4
there's only a few ideas to save me
one idea is knight c5
i went a little bit overboard here
and now i'm kind of drowning
but okay
well the one idea in the position i'm
hoping will save me
there's still ways for about to go wrong
especially if black starts thinking for
the next two minutes
that's a very safe move
maybe king a2
and queen d5 check
okay let's try this move
if queen g5 i play queen g4
i'll play knight c3 i do knight d5
some queen h4 idea then g5 and then on
poisson check
pre-move
this okay now i think there's this move
and surprisingly i might be okay
because there's some skewer here
this queen is very short on squares
not sure about queen g2 though
queen g2 knight e4 perhaps
queen f2 makes me happy
ah i miss this move and it's ripped d6
but i'll still have it
or maybe i have better like 94
immediately
even this immediately
okay this is uh
this is going well
there we go
black didn't have to resign there
there's king f7 but
okay got the job done
i blundered my rook on move 19.
is either rook roll or is that real
i feel like i blundered a lot that game
move 19
i'll look later
if i remember
okay playing gleb muscalinco
staffer gamma time
or whatever this is
ooh reverse staffer gabbit
but this is now a center fork trick
idea to play d5
i could have accepted like take on c3
and went for the f6 line
but uh
this is a more aggressive way of playing
now queen d it doesn't look aggressive
but
the idea is to reroute eventually
and get out get out of danger of all the
potential attacks
okay some idea to play this move
white's playing
some natural moves
um
i would like the game to
get a bit sharper
now i am happy here having the bishop
hair
especially with white casting queen side
i really don't mind trading on d4
thank you about this up welcome back
appreciate the robot bits
it's gonna be really hard to win this
tournament
gary and osama style
showing his boss oh no my bishop
okay i thought this would lead to some
mating attack but
i may be misjudged
okay king c1 is helpful
there we go
the king could have moved the other way
to allow for queen c1
okay trying to catch up to gary
i'm still
a lot of points out of the first though
unfortunately
move 19.
yeah there's some common light under the
rook
but i'm not seeing it i probably got
rook rolled
okay let's play aggressively
uh oh someone wanted ponziani earlier
um this might transpose into ponziani
i'm attempting to play some kind of
gambit
if black doesn't take it's basically a
ponziani
because i'll take back
love you eric
oh i love you too i real z
98.
okay that's a respectable move
still trying to gambit here
opponent is not giving in though
i mean the idea would be to get some
initiative
okay there is a gambit
the question is how much initiative am i
getting here
i didn't want to allow the bishop to
develop to g4
galapagos
idea maybe rook c1 or e1
[Music]
another idea to maneuver the knight to
g6
because that pawn is pinned
i'm just trying to think aggressively
maybe rookie one e5
always good to keep in mind the
aggressive resources in the position
yeah i explained earlier why uh i turned
this ring off
because it doesn't incentivize the best
quality chess
um
that's a move
i guess i'll be down two pawns
but there's still initiative hitting the
queen pressuring this pawn
[Music]
hit the knight
and now maybe i'll get my
eventual wish
of knight g6
and bishop f5 is probably coming
ooh
okay now i'll go after this pawn
and clear target in the position
expecting some queen move
there's really not too many ways to
defend
i'm trying to figure out if knight g6
actually threatens anything
because it might but it might not
there's another funny line queen e6
knight e6
and black couldn't take
oh this is okay
what did i say earlier this is what i
was going for
i'm realizing it still might not work
for me though depending what black plays
the knight a5
but not a5 okay i have this move
and the queen is still attacked now the
knight's attacked
okay that's the dream situation
um
considering taking on f7 but
still have to be careful
there might be some weird moves for
black like d5 but
d5 there's 97 the very least
there's also bishop
d5 we would trade a bunch and then 97
end
the problem for black is um
the queen side never really developed
what to do here queen a4 i guess
eyeing the e8 square
another idea to play rook e7 just going
after the pawn
okay so here probably 97
oh i could take though
i think the tactics work if queen takes
i fork with a knight if knight takes i
fork with a rook
meanwhile i'm hitting this
bishop's doing some nice work on d5
otagi asking when are they playing or
planning to have reykjavik open
i actually don't know usually it's
sometime in april
but i'll have to check the exact dates
uh where's my mate
check
where's my mate
i don't see my mate
i'll play this move
threatening some
made in two
i needed one more thing
to attack the f7 pawn
question did you leave chefs.com
only temporarily
i was actually talking with some of the
chess.com
higher-ups
yesterday
and i'm going to plan to do a speedrun
on just.com in the very near future
just a matter of getting the account set
up
okay it's still not meat
uh
let's do this and then queen here
and
then it's about to be made
okay
that might be the last game that counts
for the tournament
gary's edging me out
also competing for the lead
or at least a third place lead
with 609 people in this tournament it's
a good turnout for kind of a last-minute
uh
event
yeah the next game
there's a good chance it's not counting
for the tournament
thank you lucas for the birthday wishes
uh even though my birthday was three
months ago
all right southern gambit time
playing breakouts
ever played before
they might
know how to punish this opening but
we'll see
okay going into the magical line
yeah opponent seems a little bit
hesitant so
it's likely they've they've at least
studied this variation
bishop is a safe move
um not too upset with getting this
though
is there's still opportunity to be
tricky
oh code in chess with yug says today i
subscribed to your youtube channel
exactly one year ago
oh happy one year subiversary
maybe you can celebrate it by
subscribing on twitch
oh no my bishop
[Music]
okay less than two minutes left
i'm attacking a pawn
now my bishop is actually probably
attacked
uh let's just
again oh no my bishop
if white takes it all oh no my queen
gotta represent the merch
we still have a merch command
for those curious
oh no my other bishop is kind of trapped
um
maybe h4
counter-attacking
if queen here i play g5 and then here i
play f4
it's a funny line
whoa we just passed the number
taggy alerted me
200 000 followers on the dot thanks to
who was it
it was
tiny snack is a 200 000 follower look at
this
tiny snack
i think
thanks everyone thanks to the newer
followers too
i just noticed
for four months subbing
oh thank you
let's go okay i feel like i have energy
now
although this game still won't count for
the tournament
unless it ends in 20 seconds
yeah thanks for all the pogs and the
hype
from twitch chat
if this goes on youtube in the future
thanks future youtube people for
watching
but the video is not over yet
there's still some unfinished business
okay i'm gonna try and save the bishop
also hitting the knight
if white takes my take with pawn
it's tempting to play b5 here
let me let's start with h3
try and undermine the whole kingside
structure
would like to play b5 at some point
question the purpose of the night
okay i could take
play c5
i'm just trying to create more pawn
tension in the position
that's one way to create
more complications
more ways for the opponent to go wrong
so now if pawn takes a bishop b4 check
if bishop takes on the pawn is a bit
more weak
wow
i'm really tempted to take with rook
let's do it
i'm going for the style points i'm also
going for getting a pawn on e3
that looks kind of nice
okay opponent doesn't take my rook
probably a good call
[Music]
i still have this move actually
but then just bishop takes
so i'll play rook c6
controlling a file
i bet they will break your victory when
i go to asia frown oh
well the first step is actually having
reykjavik open
um but going to asia sounds fun as well
what to do here we trade rooks
i don't want to trade too much
a2 is defended
if i sack a pawn
g5 is a candidate move
okay i have an idea
but a complete c5
very risky idea because i'm opening my
king
i'm trying to destabilize these two
pawns
in the process i am losing some pawns
uh yeah that's a fine move maybe g6
so at least preventing the rook from
coming in
the hope is to get the rook here the
queen here and start pressuring the
especially the light squares around the
king
okay
a lateral queen move this may be
overlooked from the opponent
i'll move back
i'm feeling very good about this
this pawn's weak
so i've only captured a single pawn this
game wait still has seven pawns
uh okay now it's time to take
d3
queen a6
oh let's play this move rook d5 just
hitting a pawn that's not defended
i'm trying to induce this so i have then
have some eventual idea to
mate
i didn't calculate this fully though
queen d4 queen h1 king f2
i mean visually it looks very good
relying on some intuition here
rook c2 inbound
bishop f3
get rook c2 coming next
here we go
okay
i got my breakout
or my breakthrough
i miss made in one dime is made one ah i
could have finished in some nice style
what do we call this
the dovetail mate
some kind of birdlike mate
with the wings and the head
i i went for the cruel and slightly
unusual punishment
oh paulette mate or apolly
that sounds french the star mates anyway
okay that was a fun tournament
thanks everyone for playing
all 627 of you
also big thank you to all
200 000 plus followers
surpassed 200 000 followers this
tournament
uh thanks trevor solving with prime
appreciate that
that was fun
thanks gauri shout out to gary for
playing
and streaming this as well
[Music]
um if this does go on youtube follow to
youtube
if you don't already know i do have a
twitch channel
you can follow
if you have amazon prime you can
subscribe for free
um i'm going to be trying to stream more
in the coming days slash weeks
it's been a very very hectic last month
between all the like work and travel
with the world championship match
but i will be back
on a normal schedule
relatively soon